items
today
we announced an upcoming conference on
hunger nutrition and health
this will bring attention to the burden
of hunger and diet related disease which
were exacerbated during the covet 19
pandemic at the conference we will
release a new national strategy to
eliminate hunger and reduce diet related
illnesses such as heart disease and
eliminate disparities the strategy will
catalyze the public and private sectors
around a coordinated strategy to
accelerate accelerate progress and drive
transformative change in the united
states also i know the president spoke
about this this morning but i just
wanted to lightly touch on the fact that
during the president's first year in
office the deficit fell by over 350
billion dollars again fell by over 350
billion dollars and that announcement
this morning his remarks were based on
the treasury department's revised
estimates of the government's financing
needs from uh for this fiscal year uh
the treasury department also announced
the president touched on it this morning
uh that uh it will pay down the national
debt this quarter for the first time
since
2016. so i just wanted to note those
items and then amer why don't you kick
us off
thanks um i had just a couple on um
related to the alito draft opinion uh
that leaked um just uh
first does the president believe that
justice kavanaugh and works such
misled or lied to senators about their
views on the road
well again given that while the while
the supreme court has validated the
document they have made clear that this
is not a final opinion
so the president i don't have anything
to speak to in terms of his views on
where members may or may not be or
supreme court justices i should say may
or may not be on a final opinion
secondly um president biden again this
morning
warned that the draft of abortion
opinion could we go beyond the issue and
jeopardize other basic rights and i
think this morning he specifically
talked about lgbtq issues yeah i
remember correctly
does he want the court does he think
that this opinion needs to be at minimum
narrowed
well again the president as much as he
spoke yesterday both in a written
statement and also to all of you who are
traveling about his strong views about
this leaked document he's not going to
prejudge or have a comment on an opinion
that has not yet been issued what he was
speaking to and i and he touched on it
again this morning was
his long history working on a range of
these issues as you all know from his
biography he
led the fight against the nomination of
robert fork and what struck him in
reading uh the the leaked document was
how some of the language reminded him of
robert bork's view of the narrow
definition of how one should
analyze or
or review what the constitution allows
for and if you remember during that
those hearings i know many of you
including myself were quite young during
the time but we all read history
part of the big debate there or the big
discussion was the griswold versus
connecticut uh
case which was related to privacy and
whether married couples should be able
to uh have the privacy to purchase
contraception and so i think what you're
hearing play out is the president's own
reaction to what he saw in these
documents and
his view that the protection of privacy
and the protection of the ability of
women to make decisions about uh their
health care with their doctors about
people to be able to choose who they
marry um and it to to him reading that
uh reminded him of how important the
those protections are and that's what he
why you continue to hear him talk about
it briefly on um chairman powell uh he
just said yeah that is limited in how it
can uh deal with uh supply shocks have
been leading the higher inflation
um
so what what more from the white house
and congress do given that challenge
well i would i would note also as you
and others have reported that there were
uh there were announcements made about
decisions uh actions the federal reserve
intends to take which are consistent
with what they have said they would do
to date and the president has said in
the past that it's appropriate um and
and he supports their their decision to
recalibrate so that remains his view
today um in terms of what more we can do
to address inflation i mean i would also
note that during his um his comments um
chair powell also noted the strength of
the economy um he also noted that uh
there's a path for a soft uh landing
without pushing the economy into
recession he had a lot to say of course
during this press conference so i just
wanted to note a couple of the things
but what more we can do beyond of course
respecting the independence of the
federal reserve and the decisions they
make including those announced today is
to continue to take steps to address
costs for the american people chair
powell also said or echoed i think it
was in response to a question the point
that energy prices and specifically the
invasion by president putin
was having an impact on inflation and so
one of the president's primary focuses
right now as you all know is taking any
step we can to bring down costs whether
that is the historic release from the
strategic petroleum reserve uh leading
the world in their own release
continuing to talk to a large uh global
providers of oil and what they can do to
help the global market even the
announcements we've made over the last
couple of weeks about e-15 and taking
any step we can to reduce those costs
and also continuing to have
conversations with leaders on capitol
hill and members about steps we can take
to reduce costs for the american people
whether it's child care health care
elder care
prescription drugs all of these have an
impact on people's day-to-day lives go
ahead back to uh abortion if i can
yesterday you said the leak raises
eyebrows including for many here in the
white house but does the white house
condemn explicitly condemn this leap and
or is seeing this draft been seen as
welcomed by some here
i don't think we have a particular view
on that other than to say that we
certainly note the unprecedented nature
of it what we are mindful of and i spoke
the president about exactly this
question yesterday and obviously it's up
to the department of justice to
determine what if any action they will
take and i know obviously there have
been calls for that from some
republicans but also members of the
supreme court but our focus is on not
losing sight from what the content is in
the draft
and what is at risk here and well we
have heard a number um raised concerns
about the leak
our focus is on highlighting
what
what what the content in there
would risk but would it risk for women
across the country so again we'll leave
at the department of justice to make a
decision about that uh i would note that
many republicans have uh wanted to talk
about that and not about whether they
support the protection of a women's
right to choose a woman's right to make
decisions with her doctor about her
health care maybe not a surprise given
more by more than a two to one margin
americans want the supreme court to
support abortion rights as the content
of the draft uh the document the draft
is of course a draft but if the supreme
court does move to strike down row
should americans be prepared to just
accept that decision as legitimate and
would president biden accept that
decision as legitimate well i can't
speak for what actions could be possible
on the legal front i would point to the
department of justice on that but what i
can tell you will happen is and this is
what we are preparing for the
possibility of that if roe were to fall
abortion would probably be illegal in
about half the states
in the country up to 26 states
particularly in the south the midwest
and west
who have all spoken out many leaders
about how they're poised to restrict or
ban access some have even taken action
even as recently as yesterday as crazy
as that sounds and depending on the
course position a decision uh 13 states
even have trigger laws trigger laws mean
they would basically immediately put in
place bans and as a result of all of
this tens of millions of women may lack
access to reproductive health care
services as soon as this summer if that
were a decision to be made i'd also note
and as we're thinking about working with
not just the gender policy council but
also the department of health and human
services also members on the hill also
the council's office what we're really
focused on is the impact uh this would
have dramatically reduced access to
reproductive care particularly for women
with low incomes women of color women in
rural communities we know that 75 of
those seeking abortions are living at or
below 200 percent of the poverty level
and the majority of patients seeking
abortions identify as black hispanic and
aapi so if you look at
the
26 states let's take for example or the
13 to 26 depending and you look at a map
that means that women the majority of
whom are below that poverty level and
are black hispanic or aapi are going to
be forced to figure out how to travel
how to take time off of work how to get
child care it is a prohibitive cost it
will not be safe
and that is what we are focused on
working to address as we're making
policy decisions and considerations it
sounds like you're saying then that's a
yes he would consider this a legitimate
decision well there is not even a
decision yet we don't know the validity
of the we know that this is a leaked
document it is not the final opinion so
i just can't speak to that
hypothetically at this point in time go
ahead jane just following up on that in
the president's statement yesterday he
said he had asked the gender policy
council on the white house's office to
look at options
what can the administration do if that's
what the decision ends up being in june
well why the reason i noted all of what
i just did jeff is because we're really
looking at who this would deeply
directly impact the most of course there
is uh the the majority overwhelming
majority of women in this country uh do
not want uh this to be overturned but
the impact directly will be
predominantly on women of color will be
on uh the 75 of those seeking abortions
who are living at or below 200 percent
of the federal poverty level so while i
can't at this point give you a preview
of what we would do in response to a
hypothetical final opinion what i can
tell you is that we've already seen
states restrict right in across the
country and if you look at texas for
example um they obviously they put their
restrictions in place and planned
parenthood and other uh organizations
have put out statistics suggesting that
clinics in neighboring states have seen
increases of 600 700 800 percent of
people traveling to their clinics so you
will see that you will see people try to
travel to states and what we've done to
date and to try to help to date where
we've seen restrictions which gives you
kind of a tiny bit of a road map even
though it would obviously be much more
expanded beyond this is created for
example the dire need grant awards which
provide funding to expand access to
emergency contraception family planning
services we just announced 6.6 million
dollars in awards made to eight grantees
across the country and around the
country
we also have
i would note the department of justice
and the attorney general's statements in
response to texas sba which again is
what is an example of what we've seen in
terms of the impact to dates and their
commitment to uh continuing to defend
the law to protect the safety of
patients seeking access to reproductive
health services hhs has also announced a
three-pronged department-wide response
to protect patients and providers so
again what we're looking at is how to
ensure we're expanding access how to
ensure we are taking a look at the
enormous impact on a specific portion of
the population um and this is in a
cross-government effort beyond just the
gender policy council
i was just going to ask would that
manifest itself in executive orders or
what specifically
might the framework for that kind of
action be we're not there yet obviously
what we've done to date jeff is taking
steps
through obviously the department of
justice which they can speak to
through grant programs and funding
programs that we've been able to put in
place to date to address even
restrictions that are in states to date
which is not the same as the supreme
court overturning um and we will build
on that from here what was the breaking
news we just learned that the secretary
of state anthony blinken has tested
positive for covid via pcr test if you
could walk us through what more you know
about that we've received a statement
from the state department but most
notably uh the most recent time he was
face to face with the president and the
circumstances the pres he's not seen the
president in several days um and he's
not considered a close contact i would
remind you all that's a strange phrase i
know but close contact as defined by the
cdc is being within uh 10 feet 15 10
feet for 15 minutes um that is not six
feet i'm sorry six feet for 15 minutes
um he has not been and has not seen him
in several days so for clarity because
we're learning about a lot of cases
right now it's not the first time
washington has seen these ricochet it's
been going on for several weeks has the
president been identified as a close
contact to anybody who is just tested
positive if he had we would have
announced that publicly to all of you
and and we have clearly made decisions
when it has been cabinet members or even
when it's been people who uh play a
public role with all of you we have uh
made announcements out of an abundance
of transparency so for transparency
purposes we know he has tested negative
recently when was the most recent
negative test he tested negative
yesterday yes the president and then
finally in terms of preventive
medications right now can you say
declaratively is the president taking
any pre-exposure
preventive medications to deal with code
he is not the preventative medication
that has been approved by the fda at
other sheld which is given to people who
are immunocompromised and he's not
immunocompromised also not taking
the mad or something i'm not aware of
any medication he is taking
thank you thank you so much
um several days since lincoln last saw
the president do you know what day
exactly that was i'm sure we can get you
the exact day
and to follow on jeff's questions when
it comes to the options that the
president has said he's directed his
team to prepare
should we not expect to see those
options until this ruling comes down
from the supreme court i that's correct
that's what i would expect do you think
it would be too late to unveil the
options then given it seems imminent
that this is the direction that the
supreme court is headed in well again we
don't have a final conclusion the
supreme court themselves made clear this
is not the final opinion so uh we will
we will be we are already working
a great deal behind the scenes and we
will have more to say uh if and when
there is a final there will be at some
point but when there's a final opinion a
question about something senator manchin
said today he said he believes inflation
will be the number one driving factor in
the midterms not abortion not this
potential ruling from the supreme court
does the white house see it that way
i mean all we can judge it based on is
what we've seen in public polls that
remains the data to date right but
obviously the news of yesterday just
came out yesterday and today the
president was sharply critical of the
maga crowd and the maga agenda is that
what we should expect to be his message
going into the midterms well i i think
for those of you who have been covering
him for some time you've heard him say
and maybe back more to the campaign
trail less as president don't compare me
to the almighty compare me to the
alternative uh and i would expect you
will hear him uh with that mantra much
more out there um over the next coming
months um you know he is um so he has
been struck clearly because he has
talked about this as you mentioned
caitlyn this morning and he also has
made comments over the last several days
about um the direction of some in the
republican party the maga direction of
some in the republican party and he's
been struck by
uh the hold his predecessor seems to
have on far too many members not all but
far too many members of the party
and what we're seeing
the latest antics
are made clear that they are at war with
mickey mouse they're against allowing
women to make choices about their own
health care against lowering the cost of
prescription drugs and if that remains
their platform the president's view is
that is out of whack with the mainstream
of the country now at the same time he's
always believed that
in working with republicans in good
faith and finding ways to do that and
he will continue to do that but he is
going to also call out and you will see
him call out more places where he feels
there are extreme
policies and and extreme uh comments and
extreme positions that um are
unfortunately overtaking far too much of
the party and you just said his
predecessor today he seemed to
purposefully say my predecessor he did
not say trump he said magga instead of
trump is that deliberate
well as far as i know
he's not on the ballot uh a number of
his uh of republicans who have uh seemed
to be under the whim of his predecessor
are so that's who he's going to focus
his efforts on
quick question about interest rates with
the fed's action today
as interest rates go up the cost of
carrying the national debt also
increases interest payments go up yeah
are there any concern about possible
complications with the president keeping
his deficit reduction pledge the cost of
paying interest on the national debt is
going to go up as interest rates going
on
i have not heard that concern expressed
by our economic team um you know we are
proud of the announcement uh made this
morning hence the president spoke to it
and taking additional steps to reduce
the deficit remain his commitment so i
have not i have not heard that concern
from them question axios is reporting
that in his meeting with mark and
different types earlier this week the
president pledged to directly engage
with syria to try to secure austin's
release is that true well i would note
that our uh hostage negotiator our our
roger carstens uh that is the type of
work that he does and will continue to
do
go ahead thanks jen why did you guys say
anything about the leaked draft memo
at the supreme court
how do you mean well in the past you
have declined to comment on leaked
materials so
why now well peter i think as you would
note and was reported the supreme court
confirmed this this document was
accurate even it was if it is not the
final opinion the president had a
statement out before they confirmed that
it was real so and in that statement he
made clear we don't know if this is
accurate uh we don't know if this
document is accurate or the leak is
accurate and to follow up on a question
earlier do you guys think does the
president think the leaker should be
punished again that's up for the
department of justice and others to
determine uh what our focus is on is not
getting our uh distracted or eye off the
ball of what is most important to people
across the country here which is not the
leak and the story of the leak is the
fact that women's health care
is at risk for millions of people across
this country the president said today
what happens if the united states change
the law saying that children who are
lgbtq
can't be in classrooms with other
children what is he talking about well i
think peter we've seen
extreme laws that target
lgbtq families their kids across the
country and i think what he's saying is
we don't know what they're capable of
given what they've already done to date
which state is trying to segregate lgbtq
children in the classroom well i think
we've seen laws that are incredibly
discriminatory that's what the
president's referring to and the fact
that
he doesn't know what additional steps
could be taken by extreme wings of the
party that would rather divide uh rather
than work on issues that the american
people actually are focused on actually
impacting them so
another one about abortion why is the
president talking about the judgment to
choose to abort a child
the president's view on a woman's right
to make choices about her own health
care is well known well documented
well-stated
i understand peter but what i'm telling
you is what is position
how can you guys say this is not a
political issue
when the president's statement about
this talked about getting pro-choice
officials elected did i say it's not a
political issue uh yes you actually said
some call it a political issue it is not
a board well because the vast majority
of the public believes that this should
not that this should not be overturned
meaning i meant to say it's not a
partisan issue and i don't think it is
there are many republican and
independent women men
across the country who do not believe
the supreme court should overturn a
woman's right to make choices about her
own health care in fact only 30 percent
in recent polls thought they should so
that's what i'm referring to
go ahead jim thanks a couple on thorough
um opinion
earlier this year president biden made a
speech on voting rights he said they
were under attack it was important to do
that will he make an address to the
nation on abortion access i don't have
anything to predict about a address to
the country uh i can tell you that
you've heard him speak about his views
today and yesterday and it's only been
two days since we saw the leaked
documents and on the comments today on
yesterday when he was asked about
abortion the president really focused on
privacy lgbt children married couples
why isn't he speaking more directly
about how this impacts women poor women
women of color how comfortable is he
talking about this
he has he did yesterday both in his
written statement and when he addressed
this publicly his point as he's
continued to talk about this over two
days is also that this brings into
question our fundamental rights and the
fundamental rights of people across this
country on who they marry what choices
they make about their own health care
and that goes to his own experience
fighting against again robert bork uh in
uh in his nomination many years ago and
he's not used the word abortion it was
in his statement yesterday
until yesterday that's my question he
hadn't used the word abortion until
yesterday why did he want to use it
yesterday and what should we take from
that when he talks about the his
protections his commitment to protecting
a woman's right to choose women's health
care he's referring to protecting
women's right to have an abortion i
think most people know that go ahead
uh yesterday the president was giving a
speech and
when he was talking about the chip spell
he said that the chinese communist party
was lobbying against the lobbying folks
to close the bill
um
i'm wondering
what you guys saw to sort of add that it
was a new line in this speech what you
saw um and what some of the examples of
them sort of interfering with our
domestic
i think what he's referring to is the
fact that it's been well reported maybe
even by bloomberg i don't know i'd have
to check
that the chinese communist party is
opposed to this legislation and that's
what he's referring to and um you know
he believes as you know that it's
absolutely critical for our national
security for congress to get this
bipartisan innovation act to his desk in
large part because it will help protect
critical supply chains like
semiconductors it goes it's going to
strengthen our supply chains against
global shocks it's going to help out
compete the rest of the world including
china uh for decades to come so he was
referring to their opposition
right their opposition to it exactly
there was an accident report uh that had
kind of two parts that i wanted to ask
you about first that the trip to israel
was going to be added to the european
trip in june but also more substantively
that um they're considering or you're
considering a regional leader summit um
as part of that visit can you confirm
either we're not quite there yet um what
i will say is that um he he you know
about the the trip at the end of june
because there are some predetermined
kind of international fora that he will
be a part of um and uh when he spoke
with prime minister bennett just a
couple of weeks ago he invited him to
israel the president accepted and said
he's looking forward to coming but we
haven't quite locked in the date yet um
and so i don't have any further detail
at this point then last summer last
question both on summits as well the
summit of the americas is coming up yeah
mexico and president had a conversation
a few days ago yeah leader of mexico has
been pushing for countries of
authoritarian governments cuba
uh venezuela and nicaragua to
participate in that summit and i'm
wondering if you guys have come to
determination about how you're going to
handle their participation
i'm happy to check i'm not sure a final
determination has been made or i will
check if one has and we can get you that
information go ahead thanks jen uh
building on some of the questions
catherine was asking just in regards to
keeping the focus on women's rights
health rights protecting privacy how
much of
the president's efforts moving forward
will be on these issues does it does it
shoot to the top of the agenda
so far it's largely been in response to
the leak does it
how much will be proactively taken now
well i would dispute that only and only
because um we have just haven't talked
about this a lot publicly but i would
note that remember that when these
states have taken actions
we've also made clear
that there was work that the gender
policy council that the white house
counsel's office the department of
health and human services obviously the
department of justice would be taking
and would be underway and we have been
in touch with leadership about this
issue and and the threat uh to row in
both chambers as well as the senate
judiciary committee chair durbin the
house women's caucus
yes in the last 36 hours but also many
times in advance about that and
certainly the leaked document is going
to intensify um after our efforts after
the news that millions of americans
health care is on the cusp of being
thrown into turmoil there's no question
about that but there's been work by the
gender policy council that's been
ongoing for months there's been work and
engagement with leaders on the hill
about what can be done for months and
certainly it's going to be redoubled at
this point given the leaked document on
that point of intensifying efforts what
what will that look like are we talking
oval office meetings uh will he travel
on this issue those kind of things
i don't have anything to predict in
terms of his schedule at this point but
what i can tell you is that as you've
seen this is an issue he has proactively
talked about in the last two days both
of the two days since the document
leaked the vice president went and gave
a
rousing speech at emily's list last
night and but most a lot of the most
important work is going to happen behind
the scenes and that is going to be the
work that is done across the government
to determine and prepare for what steps
can be taken should this final decision
be made on title 42 um mexico's foreign
minister uh mentioned uh i think in the
day last day or two that the biden in
spring administration is expected to
present a formal set of ideas uh to the
government on how to contain the
expected rise and migration um i assume
or can you share whether the white house
is working with the dhs on those set of
ideas and is there anything you can
share and what those are well i would
say first that as you know secretary
mayor has testified and laid out six
very specific pillars of effort and work
that we would be pursuing and some of
that of course is directly with
countries in terms of addressing root
causes addressing
actions or attempts by smugglers to take
advantage of this moment
and working with the mexican government
as part of that and the president's
conversation and call was put together
in order to discuss preparations for the
lifting of title 42. as part of that the
the tasking was there for there to be
follow-up from members of our national
security team and mexico that's
continuing but i don't have any
specifics to read out for you that was
just always intended to be the follow-up
staff go ahead uh thanks dan i wanted to
pivot to ukraine uh secretary austin
recently said and i want to get the
quote right
we believe that we can win they can win
they can win if they have the right
equipment the right support
how does the administration actually
define
winning in ukraine and does it mean that
every last russian troop is out
well first i would say the way that
president putin defined defined winning
a war that he started from the beginning
was taking over ukraine uh and
enveloping ukraine into russia taking
away their territorial integrity and
their sovereignty clearly that has not
been successful you know he expected and
was planning to be marching through the
streets of kyiv victorious next monday
clearly that is not what is going to
happen he wanted this to be
a moment to divide nato to divide the
west clearly that is not what is
happening uh we've said we want ukraine
to win we're going to do everything we
can to help ukraine defend its
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and to strengthen the ukrainians hands
on the battlefield and at the
negotiating table that's our role and
they are defending their homeland
courageously and bravely from the
continued attacks from the russians but
they're going to define
at the negotiating table as we're
strengthening our hand what they
consider success um on the battlefield
and at the negotiating table and we're
here to support their efforts i just
want to follow up to make sure i'm clear
so if ukraine is fine with russia taking
over the eastern part of the country for
example is that what the us would
consider a win is that what the
ukrainians are going to define what a
successful outcome looks like for them
but what i think is important to note
and not lose sight of is how the
russians have defined this and they have
already lost that by their definition
they have not taken over ukraine
president putin is not going to be
marching through down the streets of
kiev they will not own the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of this
country they have not divided nato so
now at this point yes what we're trying
to do is strengthen their hand in the
negotiating table both by supplying
weapons on the battlefield both and
supporting them with whatever needs they
have but it is for them to define
through those negotiations
two questions uh abortion related um the
president promised during the campaign
to overturn the restrictions that the
trump administration put on the aca's
requirement that workplace insurance
plans cover contraception yeah and the
agencies said in august that they would
initiate rulemaking within six months
and that hasn't happened why hasn't it
happened is it still going to happen i i
it is still the president's intention
i'm happy to check on the status and and
why why there has been any delay and
then following up on catherine's
question on the president using the word
abortion yesterday and today just to be
more specific about it was that a
conscious choice to use that word since
he hadn't been using it much before did
he specifically now that the stakes are
much higher did you specifically start
using word abortion because of that
no he he approved the statement
made comments of his own accord today so
i don't think there's more to analyze
about it
go ahead good job um
the president toured the mega as you
referred to he called him an extremist
group and he also issued a statement on
ohio today but he was talking about
chantal brown in the democratic primary
so the question is uh what is his
reaction to
the republican senate primary and does
he view that as trump gaining more
control over the senate and the process
potentially what happens two years from
now i'm going to be very careful about
getting into the midterms here um i
don't make the rules i just follow the
rules um from this podium um and i know
the president of course as you noted
jeff spoke to
uh made comments himself this morning
about the extreme direction the
republican party is going and um so uh
look i would just say um
our focus continues to be on uh
highlighting uh the fact that
congressional republicans want to raise
taxes on half of americans squeezing the
budgets of middle class families if you
don't believe me you can check out
senator scott's website i guess he's
called for that and we certainly agree
we hope you check out his website i'm
touring about maggot today uh i think he
i i've answered this a little bit
earlier but i'm happy to reiterate you
know he has been struck by the hold uh
his predecessor seems to have on far too
many members of the party
and while he has always worked in good
faith will continue to work in good
faith on addressing issues the american
people have whether it is bringing down
costs expanding access to health care
and there are areas where we feel we can
have continued success who who is
opposed to addressing opioids or making
doing more to help veterans and address
burn pits but he's still going to call
out where he sees extremist actions and
extremist rhetoric and i'm just not
going to get into specific outcomes of
the primaries from here abortion aspect
elizabeth warren said she was angry by
that draft opinion was the president
angered by the draft i think you heard
anger in his voice yesterday for sure go
ahead
yesterday you said the president was
still reviewing the report from his
presidential commission on the supreme
court that was issued several months ago
i guess i'm wondering why that review is
taking so long and is there any renewed
urgency on that review given the draft
that we've seen leaked from the court
well i think it's important to remember
that the report was never meant to be
recommendations in fact it's not
recommendations it was an analysis done
by 30 legal experts with a diversity of
backgrounds and diversity of views
about a range of issues not just court
expansion but term limits and a range of
issues um so but it was never intended
to have an outcome where he came out and
said i accept or decline recommendations
it was just a resource he was looking to
have and one he appreciates and will
continue to review is there any uh
renewed urgency though around weighing
in on that report and what those
experts you know
put together on the court since we've
seen this draft come out though in what
aspect
seeing uh you know
there was a lot of discussion around
term limits that was in that report uh
any anything about the issues that they
studied specifically and well it wasn't
meant to be a recommendation
anything that uh the president has you
know claimed could be
made changes to the board i don't have
any different or new announcements or
positions to announce today uh his focus
and he believes all of our focus needs
to be on what we're doing to protect
women's rights and women's access to
health care and that's where his efforts
will be focused in the foreseeable
future but thanks jeff this morning when
the president was talking about the
deficit he said my plan to continue
reducing the deficit and he rattled off
a couple of uh agenda items uh including
prescription drug reform tax incentives
or green energy changes the tax code
some pieces of the oil built back better
and i just wonder what is the
president's plan to getting that through
the senate given the narrowing
legislative window for this year to
continue having conversations about it
that we don't talk about publicly and
encouraging members to have
conversations with each other to see if
we can come to a point where we have 50
votes to support a package moving
forward this point doesn't seem like
that's the case given that senator
manchin is off with you know trying to
do a climate bill through a bipartisan
working group and senator cinema
continues to oppose changes to the tax
code so
i'm just i think there's a lot happening
behind the scenes in congress that
people are declining to talk about go
ahead and thank you two questions please
um the
mega crowd as you call them today this
was almost half the people who voted in
uh 2020.
does the president feel maybe that could
have been done he could have done more
early on trying to reach out to those
people and does does the extreme
pressure uh
basically signal that you know there's
no going back now and they're there
they're sort of out of you know beyond
the pale for him and
yeah
i think but the president one the
president will be judged by americans by
his actions and what he does to make
their lives better and the point he's
making is that um there are the platform
of uh and the policies of uh many far
too many of these republicans these mega
republicans as he refers to them
follow the whims of calling out
mickey mouse and opposing policies that
will help make the lives better of many
many americans who
may have voted for trump may have been
independent may be democrats
including lowering the cost of
prescription drugs lowering the cost of
elder care doing more to expand access
to health care and his view is that a
lot of these
policy positions and the rhetoric is
extreme and that follows uh what we saw
a pattern of uh by his his predecessor
but he is going to continue to look for
ways to work together and work together
uh with republicans in good faith where
there's opportunity and he believes you
can do both
thank you a totally different question
on the sanctions i know he said that
he's going to be discussing that this
week and
yeah how much left of the week um
is patriarchal a possible target of
sanctions and more generally if you
don't want to comment on that
um does the president ever talk about
patriarchy he's a religious man and he's
obviously keenly interested in other
countries religions um
he's he's emerged as a pretty remarkable
figure and you know has been sanctioned
by the eu the pope called him
said don't be putin's altar boy does the
president ever talk about
i would say no one is safe from our
sanctions we're continuing to review
options but i don't have any to preview
today
go ahead uh follow up on those sanctions
um there's seems to be a few holdouts uh
in within the eu especially hungary for
example they're not so much on board
with uh especially the oil ban is there
any effort from the administration to
sort of engage at any level on that
topic to try to convince or
give incentives to those holdouts to
sort of get on board with the rest of
the eu
well i mean our view
um you know we of course broadly support
uh europe's efforts to deny putin
revenue to fund his war with the eu's
new proposal uh but it will be up to
them to finalize um we've taken strong
action uh to ban russian energy but we
have also been very clear
that we have always uh understood that
europe and many countries in europe are
in different circumstances so we'll
continue to work with a range of
countries um you know and and um applaud
uh efforts to deny uh putin's revenue uh
revenue to fund his war but i don't have
any specific diplomatic engagement to
read out here just wouldn't be
constructive
uh on abortion if the draft decision
were to be sustained uh obviously with
overturned railroad it would also
overturn casey
and as you know at the core of casey
is the question of whether governments
can require women
to get
parental consent
or spousal notice good spousal notice
uh do you have a comment on that element
of this i'm just not gonna get ahead of
a a final opinion that has not yet been
issued and then uh just on the summary
of the americas
um
the secretary of state recently spoke
with yeah
expressed
uh continued support for glydo is he
invited into the summit let me see i
know there's a lot of interest in this
and it's coming up soon so let me see if
we can get you all just kind of a broad
summary to the group of where things
stand on the invitations good question
this is throwing me off but go ahead
i was double booked and he's very good
yes yes yes of course
you've been asked most of what i was
wondering about abortion and um ukraine
but i am curious about this and this
follows up on the question about
patriarch carrill yeah the pope this
week gave an interview to an italian
newspaper
um offered to meet with vladimir putin
in moscow to try brokering the ceasefire
and says he thinks nato's presence in
countries near russia
perhaps facilitated the invasion of
ukraine
has the president spoken directly at all
to pope francis about the war
i'm not aware of any recent calls he has
had with the pope would he have any
concern or preference about the pope
going to russia and potentially
i've not discussed that with him but i
would suspect that he would respect the
decisions of the pope to make any travel
or engagements that he so chooses you
said they speak or they've communicated
regularly you have any sense of when the
last time might have been i'd be to
check if there's more we can read out
for all of you of course um go ahead
thanks john um two questions can you
just preview what tomorrow's
announcement of the administration's
china strategy is going to look like and
can you walk us through what's that
behind the scenes
the state department um so i would
really leave it to them to preview but i
have nothing to to preview for you from
here okay if i can just ask about taiwan
um the taiwanese government said
yesterday that due to limited american
production capacity the delivery of u.s
howitzers will be significantly delayed
by several years and anti-aircraft
missiles may also be affected so are you
concerned that these long delays and
inventory issues will impact taiwan's
efforts to potentially fend off a
chinese i would really point you to the
defense department to validate that or
confirm where they are with these
deliveries
good about the summits next week we have
the asean summit in the covents yeah
which one would you like me to ask about
first whatever one you'd like let's
start with asean and let's just ask what
does the us hope to achieve at the asean
summit are you looking to contain china
or to isolate russia and have you
planned to achieve i i'm happy we will
have more to preview about it as we get
closer um we're just not quite there yet
so looking at the covet summit then um
with this funding still in limbo what
does the u.s hope to be able to bring to
the table and please be specific as you
can what does the us plan to offer in
the global fight against against covet
including maybe therapeutics vaccines so
on and so forth well i'm not going to
tell you all of our announcements
several days in advance that wouldn't be
a very effective communication strategy
what i will tell you in terms of our
objectives for this
summit are to uh to have focused
attention um at the summit on the need
as a global community to continue to do
more to address the pandemic and we have
done far and away more than the rest of
the world we have talked in the past
about the importance of other countries
in other developed countries doing more
not just on vaccines but providing
know-how capacity storage capacity the
range of tools that a rick that
countries need and we also know that
it's not about just getting shots in
arms or it's not just about the vaccines
themselves it's about um ensuring that
um we are providing um you know
expanding protecting the health
workforce expanding supply of oxygen
facilities enhancing access to medical
counter measures these are all steps
that we hope to and plan to discuss
there
it is there's no question that um we
will be advocating between now and then
and and likely then as well for how this
shines a light on why we need more
funding not just domestically but
internationally so that we can continue
to be the arsenal of vaccines for the
world and this is an opportunity to do
exactly that but it should not be lost
that the united states regardless of
that continues to be far and away the
largest contributor to the global uh
fight against the pandemic
springboarding on something that my
colleague here asked about
commitments to allies like taiwan yeah
and to customers yeah can can washington
assure these allies and customers that
you still have their back that you still
can support them in in helping them
defend themselves
i i think nothing has changed about our
policy toward taiwan or any of our other
other uh partners around the world that
we have worked very closely with um and
i don't think there's any reason to
question that but i was pointing her to
the department of defense who can speak
to the delivery of weapons and materials
that they have greater access to that
information go ahead thanks john i
wanted to ask about the refugees from
ukraine can you provide an update on
your program that launched about a week
ago
any update on people that have
volunteered to sponsor refugees or
interests from refugees abroad
to enter the program to the degree we
have those numbers to provide the
department we would but someone has them
but they're in the department of
homeland security and they're overseeing
the implementation of the program as you
know i'm happy to check with them but
you may want to go to them more directly
and when was the last time that the
president
spoke with the department of homeland
security on the refugee program or was
briefed on
the updates on the program he's been
briefed repeatedly on the on the program
throughout the development of it um and
and certainly will continue to be
briefed on the status
um i wanted to ask about brittany
grinder i know you've responded to many
questions about her but with the
olympians being here at the white house
today of course she would potentially
have been one of them and she's away in
russia being detained right now i wonder
if you can update the public on why her
situation is different
because you've mentioned that
it is not a normal hostage situation so
it's a bit different can you explain to
the public um why her situation is
different and then i have one on
abortion well i i would note that
actually the state department uh changed
the how they classify and this is up to
them to change um her uh just a couple
of days ago um it doesn't mean that we
are going to get into detail here about
our efforts because our focus is on
hopefully bringing her home and being
successful at that
but the state department determined the
russian federation has wrong wrongfully
detained u.s citizen brittany greiner
they made that assessment about two days
ago we're going to continue to undertake
efforts to provide appropriate support
to her and what this notes with this
determination is that the special
process presidential envoy for hostage
affairs roger carson so i mentioned
earlier uh will lead the interagency
team for securing her release um so well
we're not gonna of course get into
internal deliberations or efforts um
this uh you know the department
basically reviews cases of u.s nationals
to maintain abroad to determine if they
are unlawful or wrongful and this review
assesses the facts of the case against
numeral criteria numerous criteria and
they made that conclusion just two days
ago that changed our strategy on how
we're working to get her to come back
well again as i noted what it means is
that the espresso press special
presidential envoy for hostage affairs
roger carson's will lead the interagency
team and then real quick on abortion um
a christian conservative um his name is
albert muller has commented on president
biden's stance in an unusual position on
abortion i'm now quoting he said that he
and his administration do not trust the
public and various areas to have the
right to determine whether or not
abortion should be legal in that area or
not
so he's essentially saying that biden
does not think that states should have
the rights to determine how abortions
to the degree that abortion the
president believes that it should
continue to be federal law that women
have the right to make choices with
their doctors as it has been for 50
years and i would just say with all due
respect to the person you mentioned even
a fox news poll earlier this month
showed that 63 percent of americans want
road to stand so i think that's actually
kind of an outlier position as it
relates to the american public go ahead
thank you i'd like to ask a question
about indo-pacific strategy people are
talking about indo-pacific economic
framework
and allies and partners are anxious that
we're not given the information on what
this framework is going to look like yes
it's going to replace something like tpp
or could you uh give us some preview
of what this framework is going to be
about and if this is going to the issue
when the president
i just don't have anything to preview at
this point i know there's a lot of
interest in his trip to asia
understandably it's going to be a great
trip but we'll have more we'll bring
jake sullivan or others to the briefing
room to preview everything about the
trip for all of you i certainly
recognize that
the summit of the americas is coming up
very soon so i will work and i hopefully
get you guys all more preview
information after this uh briefing and
maybe we'll have more to say tomorrow um
okay thanks so much
thank
everybody